I usually say I'm South African and I've
retained the accent and I think that
must have some sort of deep
psychological reason and and you know I
think more and more for people this is
you know the reality of life in a in a
globalized world it's less and less the
exception and you know you could
complain about endlessly and say you
have no home and but it's also this
incredible privilege to move between
countries and so I try and remind myself
of that anytime you know I am about to
fall into the trap of self-pity you know
having family members my parents are now
in Australia my sisters in London I'm in
New York and it is a dilemma of you know
how does a family ever didn't find its
way back to one another after so long
living apart but at the moment it still
feels more like a lucky